BÁLINT PATÓ: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our talk.
In this session,
we'll show you how
you can develop
your applications
in IDEs using Cloud Code if
you're deploying to Cloud Run.
My name is Bálint Pató.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
And I was the lead for the
project delivering the Cloud
Run experience for Cloud Code.
MATTHEW MICHIHARA: And I'm Matt.
I'm also an engineer at
Google on the Cloud Code team.
BÁLINT PATÓ: Before
we jump into the IDEs,
for those who are
unfamiliar with Cloud Run,
let's see briefly what
the Cloud Run actually is.
Cloud Run enables you to
run stateless containers
in a fully managed environment.
These stateless
container instances
are spun up when the
application endpoint is
triggered on demand.
If the application
receives no requests,
however, these instances
scale back down to zero.
Depending on what
your preference is,
you have two flavors of Cloud
Run that you can work with.
The fully managed
environment is a pay
as you go service with
zero need for managing
any kind of infrastructure,
meaning no servers,
no clusters are required.
However, it is a
cloud-only option.
Cloud Run for Anthos runs Cloud
Run workloads on GKE clusters,
enabling customers
to run workloads
wherever Anthos can run, for
example, in your data center,
on premises.
Cloud Run is
typically used to run
web applications, public APIs,
or backends for mobile apps.
You can choose to make these
stateless containers, however,
private as well--
as part of a larger
application, for example,
microservice or executing
tasks based on events or part
of your ETL pipeline.
This all sounds great in theory.
However, it is actually easier
to show what Cloud Run is
than explaining it.
So let's deploy a sample
app using the Cloud
Console and the command line.
To deploy an application to
Cloud Run from my browser,
I'm going to use
Google Cloud Console.
Let's choose the Cloud Run
tab, Create Service button.
My choice of
deployment platform is
going to be the fully
managed Cloud Run service.
And I'm going to deploy
it to us-central1 region.
The service name is
something simple.
I'm going into let anybody
access this application.
It's going to be public.
And for the
application, I'm going
to use a prepared,
pre-built application
that is just a simple web
app listening on port 8080,
and that's it.
I'm just going to hit
Create, and Cloud Run
will deploy my application.
So at any time I
hit the endpoint,
the response is going to be
coming from an instance that
was spun up on demand.
And there it is.
So let's do something
similar on the command line
starting from code.
So I have a simple
Go application
that uses a Docker file to
build an image out of it.
So let's build it.
And I'm going to
push it as well.
"docker push" to this GCR--
Google Container Registry--
URL in my project, so
that "gcloud run deploy"
can deploy it.
I'm going to go through a
very similar set of choices.
So the fully managed
platform is my choice
of deployment platform.
Service name is going to be--
let's name it goapp123.
And the us-central--
going to be the region.
And my application is
going to be yes, public.
G Cloud does the same thing
that Cloud Console did.
It asks Cloud Run to deploy
this container image,
so when I hit this
endpoint, my new instance
is going to respond,
write "Hello, world!"
That was great.
Isn't Cloud Run just awesome?
As soon as you have
a container, you
can just run it in the cloud.
Fantastic.
But then the questions come,
how do we get to that container?
Also, do I always need
to use the command
line or the browser?
Luckily, that is exactly what
we're going to talk about here.
So let's have a
look at the agenda.
We covered what Cloud Run is.
Next, Matt will explain
what Cloud Code is.
And then we'll show you
a bunch of demos starting
from the IDEs, where we
will deploy from VSCode,
and we'll develop a more
complex application in IntelliJ.
On to you, Matt.
MATTHEW MICHIHARA:
Thanks, Bálint.
Cloud Run is great,
but developing
for it can be challenging
without the right tools.
For example, if you're new
to Cloud Run, getting started
might seem a little
intimidating.
It can be difficult to know
how to build a container.
Once your application is
containerized for Cloud Run,
developing and
debugging it locally
is not as straightforward
as it would
be with a non-containerized
application.
Finally, there are many tools
to assist with Cloud Run,
but it would be nice not
to have to constantly
context switch between the
CLI, web browser, and editor.
This is where a
Cloud Code comes in.
Cloud Code is a set
of tools for IntelliJ
and Visual Studio
Code that helps
you write cloud-native
applications, including
applications for Cloud Run.
Cloud Code is integrated with
sample projects in Java, Go,
Python, and Node.js to help
you get started setting up
your Cloud Run application.
Cloud Code can help you
containerize your existing
application and will simulate
the Cloud Run environment
locally.
This lets you develop your
app in an environment that
is very close to production,
while letting you use your IDE
to do things like set
breakpoints and debug.
Once you're ready to
deploy, Cloud Code
makes that easy too, by
hooking into the IDE's existing
deployment mechanisms.
And you can view
previous deployments
in the Cloud Run Explorer.
Cloud Code is available
for free for Visual Studio
Code and the JetBrains IDEs
from the respective plugin
marketplaces.
We have public issue
trackers on GitHub,
and we'd love to hear if you
have any feedback after trying
it out.
Now on to the fun stuff.
Bálint is going to show you how
to get started with Cloud Code
for VSCode.
BÁLINT PATÓ: Remember when I
asked how you can deploy an app
from the IDE without the use
of the browser or the command
line?
Well, let's see our
first demo from the IDE.
I have VSCode installed,
and that has IntelliJ.
So I'm going to show a
VSCode-based demo first.
In this demo, we'll see how you
can create a simple application
and deploy it to Cloud Run using
Cloud Code for Visual Studio
Code.
After you install the extension
from the VSCode marketplace,
you can confirm that it is
activated by seeing a Cloud
Code button in the status bar.
Let's start by creating a
new sample application first.
And we'll click on
the Cloud Code button
to bring up the
available commands,
then hit New Application
and Cloud Run application.
The available languages for
sample applications are Java,
Python, Node.js, Golang, and C#.
I will create my sample
application written in Go.
My application is created now.
It is a simple web application
that listens on port 8080.
It has a Docker file.
It has a simple Go
file and a test file.
And in the README, we can
see that the next step
is to open the command
palette and run the Cloud Code
deployment command.
So let's do that.
I'm going to enter "Cloud
Code deploy," and there it is.
Cloud Code recognizes
that I'm logged into GCP
with my account using G Cloud.
It automatically
selects the project
that I set as the default one.
Let's walk through
the options to deploy.
Most of these should be very
familiar from the Cloud Console
options that I demoed earlier.
Let's start with the
Service Settings.
Cloud could allows me to create
a new revision of an existing
service or to create
a new service.
I will create a new service and
name it hello-nextonair-world.
As I explained, we
have the two flavors
of the deployment platform--
for Cloud Run,
the fully managed,
and Cloud Run for Anthos.
I am going to deploy
to fully managed
using the us-central1 region.
I'm going to keep my
application public.
And the Revision Settings
show the opportunity
for setting some advanced
settings for my application,
including the container image
URL, where the application is
going to be pushed up to, and
the other advanced options.
The Build Settings
are something that
is different from the
Cloud Console settings.
This is what sets up how the
application is going to be
built into a Docker image.
Cloud Code recognizes that
my application can be built
using Docker or Buildpacks.
I'm going to choose
Buildpacks, because that's
the cooler option.
Because I don't have to write a
single line of Docker file code
or know what Docker is, it
just builds my application
into a Docker image.
So let's hit Deploy.
As my application
builds and deploys,
I should be able to
see, after it succeeds,
that my new service should
show up between my projects.
Cloud Code provides
a Cloud Run panel
that has a Cloud Run
explorer which, as we see,
shows the list of
services in my project.
Hello-nextonair-world,
my newly created service,
just showed up.
We can see in the
Properties panel
that it has the service
name hello-nextonair-world.
It has a URL, where
it's deployed,
us-central region, as expected.
And it has one
serving revision which
has 100% of the traffic
allocated to it.
I can check the logs
for this revision.
And by right-clicking
on the service,
I can also open the
URL for my application.
And there it is.
Before we continue, I wanted
to add two more notes.
Local development
features are going
to be released later
in August, and they
will be available in
both VSCode and IntelliJ.
I did not demo them, because we
didn't have time for it here.
However, Matt will show
you, inside IntelliJ,
the local development features.
The second note is about
the Artifact Registry.
While we are showing
Google Container Registry
in our demos, I recommend
you to check out
Google Artifact Registry,
which is currently in beta.
And it will provide the
next generation of features
for storing, amongst
other artifacts,
Docker containers as well.
MATTHEW MICHIHARA:
Thanks, Bálint.
Next, I'll be
showing you how you
can do some local development
using Cloud Code for IntelliJ.
In this next demo,
I'm going to walk
through how we can update
an existing Cloud Run
application to talk to
an external database.
We'll then iterate on
some changes, debug it,
and finally, deploy
it back to Cloud Run.
Here's an application
currently deployed
to Cloud Run that lets you vote
on your preferred indentation
preferences, tabs or spaces.
As you can see here, this
app keeps a running count
of votes for tabs and spaces
and shows Recent Votes
down at the bottom here.
Each time I vote,
my vote is recorded,
and the Recent Votes
section is updated.
Now I'll switch to
Cloud Code for IntelliJ,
where we can examine the code.
It's a Node.js Express
app, and the bulk of it
is implemented in
this server.js file.
Now, as you can see here, there
are two main route handlers--
one for handling the
GET HTTP request and one
for handling the
POST HTTP request.
So in the GET request handler,
we get the recent votes.
We get the counts for the number
of votes for tabs and spaces.
We do some calculations
to determine
what text to display on the
screen, and then we render it.
In the Post request handler,
we receive an incoming vote,
and then we use
this castVote method
to record the incoming vote.
I'll step into this
castVote method, where
it simply takes the
vote and persists it
to our in-memory "votes" array.
So here is what the current
architecture looks like.
So there's a problem with this.
As you can see here, the way
we implemented our data store
is in-memory, inside
the container.
And this is a problem,
because Cloud Run
is designed to work
with stateless,
ephemeral containers.
So when Cloud Run scales
down to zero or scales up,
this data will be lost.
We can avoid this data loss and
make our container stateless
by moving our data store
out of the container
and by having our container
talk to an external database.
So let's try to implement
this with Cloud SQL, which
is GCP's managed SQL database.
Here is what our desired
architecture will look like.
I've gone ahead and created
that "votes" table in the Cloud
Console and updated the code
to talk to that database.
You can see that I replaced
the methods here with ones
that execute SQL queries.
For full details
on the changes I
made, check out the
code in the GitHub
repo linked in the slides.
So we just made
a lot of changes,
and I could push this
directly to Cloud Run
to see if it works, but
I don't want to do that.
Normally, I'd want to test
my changes out locally first
before deploying to production.
Cloud Code lets me do that by
providing a simulated Cloud Run
local development
environment to test on.
So let's try that out
using the Cloud Run "Run
locally" run configuration.
I have one set up here that
I'll quickly run through.
I've named it "Run
locally" and configured
it to build my application
using the Docker builders,
since there is a Docker
file present in my project.
Cloud Code has also detected
that my project is buildable
using Buildpacks, which is a
container-building technology
that will automatically
containerize
my application without the
need for a Docker file.
But since we have a Docker file,
we can just stick with that.
In the Advanced
revision settings
here, I've also
configured my application
with the environment variables,
SQL connection string,
and service account required to
talk to the Cloud SQL database.
Full details on these are
also provided in the link
to GitHub repository.
So let's try it out.
Clicking Play here will start
the Cloud Code simulated Cloud
Run environment.
Internally, Cloud
Code is using tools
like Skaffold and Minikube to
build, containerize, and run
my application in
a local Kubernetes
cluster behind the scenes.
All right, it looks like
it was able to run my app.
We can launch it by
going to the Event Log
here and clicking this link.
And here's my app
running locally.
You can see it's running on
localhost in the Cloud Run
simulated environment.
I can cast votes, and it
looks like they're properly
persisted.
But let's just double
check to make sure,
and I can do that by
going back to my terminal
and checking to see if they're
actually saved to Cloud SQL.
So I'm going to quickly write
a SQL query to verify this.
And yep, it looks like the
votes I cast were properly
saved in the votes table.
So that's great.
To recap, Cloud Code helped
me containerize and run
my application in a simulated
Cloud Run environment
so that I could test
my application locally
before deploying the Cloud Run.
When I'm developing
a Cloud Run app,
I want quick feedback loops.
I want to make changes and
see those changes reflected
quickly so that I can iterate.
And I don't want to have
to manually build an image
and redeploy to
Cloud Run each time
I want to test my
application out.
Fortunately, Cloud Code
makes that easy for me
by automatically building
and redeploying my app
to a local simulated
Cloud Run environment
when it detects source changes.
So let's see that in action.
Let's say I want to add
some extra exclamation
points to the end of this text.
I'll go to my IDE and add
some exclamation points.
When I hit Save, Cloud
Code detect the change
and automatically rebuilds
and redeploys my container.
This keeps the inner
development loop tight so
that I can quickly iterate.
All right, so now if I go back
to my app and refresh the page,
my change is reflected there.
Notice how I didn't need to
craft and run multiple Docker
commands in order to
redeploy my changes,
since Cloud Code automatically
took care of that for me.
Let's see how Cloud Code
helps me debug my Cloud Run
application.
Normally, debugging code
running inside containers
can be tricky.
There are source mappings to
configure and ports to forward,
and each language handles
it a bit differently.
Cloud Code takes care
of all of this for me
by utilizing Skaffold's
debugging capabilities
under the hood.
My application has a
bug that I've planted.
If spaces start winning,
their win count goes negative.
So Cloud Code lets me debug this
using all the debugging tools
that I'm used to.
I don't have to modify my
Docker file to include debugging
utilities or configure ports--
Cloud Code does it for me.
I can set a breakpoint,
and then run my application
in debug mode.
So right now, Cloud Code
is configuring my container
to be debuggable.
It also detected the appropriate
path mapping for me to set up.
Now that the debugger is
attached, if I reload the page,
the breakpoint is hit,
and I can step through.
So I'll step through--
that things look right.
And here is where that
negative 1 came from.
"diff" is negative
1, and it looks
like it's because I swapped
tabCount and spaceCount.
tabCount should be
subtracted from spaceCount.
So I'm going to
fix that right now.
Save, and rerun this to
verify that it was fixed.
OK, my application is running.
So if I reload the page--
great, it looks like it's
not negative anymore,
and it's showing us
the right number.
So this looks good.
Cloud Code just helped me
debug my Cloud Run application
locally using all
the normal debugging
tools that I would
with IntelliJ,
without requiring me to
go through a complicated
configuration setup.
At this point, I feel
comfortable deploying my app
to Cloud Run on GCP.
So Cloud Code lets me do
that by using its deploy run
configuration.
This time I'm using the Cloud
Code Cloud Run deploy run
configuration.
Here, I've gone ahead
and set that up.
I've selected the
GCP projects that I'm
going to deploy this to.
Next, I configured the
deployment platform,
and I can choose between
fully managed and Cloud
Run for Anthos.
Fully managed will have GCP
manage all the infrastructure
for me, whereas
Cloud run for Anthos
will let me run my Cloud Run
application on a GKE cluster,
for example.
I'm going to stick
with fully managed,
and I'm going to deploy
this to the us-west1 region.
Here, the service name is what
my Cloud Run app is called,
so I've named it "vote."
And next, I configured the
Authentication settings.
I can either have this "Allow
unauthenticated invocations"
or "Require authentication."
And since I want this to be
a publicly available service,
I opted for allowing
unauthenticated invocations.
This field configures
where the container
images I'm building get stored.
So I'm going to stick with
Google Container Registry,
which is the default here.
I also filled out these
environment variables
that I did for the local
run [? rec ?] configuration.
And last, I configured
the builder settings
to build my container
using Docker.
So now if I hit Run on the
Cloud Code Cloud Run deploy run
configuration, it's
going to build my app,
containerize it, and deploy
it to Cloud Run on GCP.
Great, so it looks like my
application finished deploying.
If I click on the link
that it printed out for me,
it looks like it
deployed successfully,
and I can still cast votes.
So to recap, Cloud
Code just helped
me iterate on my
application, debug it,
and finally, deploy
it back to Cloud Run.
BÁLINT PATÓ: Thank
you very much, Matt.
That was a great demo.
I love Tabs VS Spaces.
So let's summarize what we've
learned today in this talk.
We've seen what
Cloud Run is, how
it makes it super easy to
run stateless containers
in the Cloud.
Then Matt explained
what the Cloud Code
is, how it sits inside VSCode
or IntelliJ as a free plugin
and makes cloud-native
development easy.
We created a simple application
in VSCode using Cloud Code,
and then I deployed it to
Cloud Run from the IDE.
Finally, Matt showed
you how to develop
and debug a more complex
application using
IntelliJ's Cloud Code local
emulator for Cloud Run
and deployed it to Cloud Run.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
I hope you enjoyed it.